hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte heute mal endlich
wieder eine motiv torte machen
ich bekomme ja auch immer mehr zuschauer
mit dazu viele fragen mich dann wie kann
ich denn mit motiv torten starten
deswegen möchte ich euch heute so eine
basic video machen
das heißt ich backmann leckeren
schokoladenkuchen machen der kanal die
braucht man nämlich um die den kuchen
daneben gerd zu streichen und ihn später
mit von dor einzudecken
ich hab jetzt heute im fussball motiv
denn meine freundin hat mich gefragt ob
ich nicht für den kleinen bruder eine
geburtstagstorte machen würde mache ich
natürlich gerne und ich zeige euch
einfach wie es geht wir starten jetzt
direkt mit dem teig und mit der creme
und ich mache das immer so ich habe mir
das jetzt auf zwei tage aufgeteilt
das heißt am ersten tag mache ich den
kuchen und die creme und die füllung und
am zweiten tag setzt sich dann den
kuchen zusammen und dekoriert eben
fertig so könnt ihr euch das zeitlich
einteilen kommt auch nicht in stress und
es macht auf jeden fall immer spaß
ich zeige mich jetzt einfach mal ganz
kurz die zutaten für den rücken
für den teig brauchen vier eier die sind
zimmer war fortan zucker wobei wenn ich
von dort hocken machte nämlich immer
weniger zucker und habe jetzt hier auf
150 gramm
ich brauche etwas vanille extrakt für
das gute aroma eine prise salz 300 gramm
mehl aber bei der schoko variante
nämlich immer 275 gramm mehl und 25
gramm kakaopulver eine warum backpulver
200 milliliter öl und 200 milliliter
flüssigkeit in meinem fall ist es
einfach mineralwasser man kann aber auch
zum beispiel likör nehmen oder einen
saft befeuchtet mit dem teig beginnen
kann ich schon mal den backwaren
einstellen ich habe hier den
verstellbaren back rahmen
kann hier außen ablesen wie groß ich ihn
machen möchte ich möchte jetzt auf 26 cm
einstellen ob seitenverkehrt und habe
hier praktisch die 26 cm und damit
nichts ausläuft muss nur den vorher noch
in bangkok er einschlagen
das geht am besten wenn ihr euch vorher
ein geschirrtuch hinlegt einfach damit
nicht rutscht darüber kommt die lage
backpapier und stand der tat kamen jetzt
will ich hier außen an und wollte den
bakken einschlagen
und dann sitzt der rat fragen ganz fest
um diese backpapier und es läuft kein
type aus und den setze ich dann einfach
gemeinsam mit dem barock hier auch mal
max theurer bach folien überhaupt
ich habe sie trotzdem gerne darunter und
so kann ich das ganze stehen lassen und
mein tag vorbereiten
für den teig gebe ich jetzt die eier in
eine rührschüssel dann kommt da die
presales mit dazu und auch der zucker
und ich gebe auch direkt ein paar
tropfen von dem man in der extrakt dazu
das ist sehr hoch konzentriert deswegen
brauche ich dann nur ganz wenig jetzt
wird es auf höchster stufe etwa fünf bis
sieben minuten lang gerührt wie es eine
schöne weiß cremige masse ist
so sollte dann die masse am ende
aussehen als ziemlich dickflüssig jetzt
könnt ihr einfach meint aber
weitermachen
jetzt gebe ich meine zwei flüssigkeiten
mit dazu öl und wasser und strom diskurs
mit einem schneebesen
und die trockenen zutaten ziehe ich
jetzt noch ein
und die werden jetzt einfach ganz locker
unterboten
jetzt fühle ich den teig in eine
backform und so kommt heute in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad ober
und unterhitze für etwa 40 minuten und
ich werde doch bereits nach 35 minuten
die stäbchen vorgemacht und zum dank
komplett auskühlen lassen sich danach
brauche ich 300 milliliter sahne und 600
gramm schokolade
ich habe jetzt hier kuvertüre genommen
und zwar habe ich das gemisch ich habe
400 peter kuvertüre und 200 gramm
vollmilch hörer einfach damit gerne
jetzt nicht zu fest werden und damit der
geschmack frische formate gerät zuerst
gebe ich jetzt die sahne in eine top
form lasse aufkochen
schalte ich den herd aus und gebe die
schokolade komplett mehr dazu jetzt muss
ich schauen dass die schokolade komplett
mit der sahne bedeckt ist und kann das
jetzt einfach zu zwei minuten stehen
lassen und western anschließend folgen
die schokolade ein bisschen gelöst jetzt
könnt ihr das ganze schön verrühren
damit sich alles zu einer homogenen
masse verbündet und deswegen ist es auch
immer besonders wichtig dass man die
kuvertüre hakt dass sich da die
korrektur besser in der sahne auflösen
kann
und dann gibt es eben auch keine
königlichen und jetzt will ich die gala
zum da würde ich gleich den deckel
verschließen kann
ich habe jetzt einen kuchen gebacken
komplett abkühlen lassen und werden
jetzt in frischhaltefolie wickeln und
dann kommt da in den kühlschrank
das heißt der kuchen ist am nächsten tag
wenn ich ihn dann benutze nicht mehr
krümelig dann wenn ich ihnen jetzt auf
schneidet ein krümel cafés er das will
ich natürlich verhindern und in der zeit
kann auch meine kanal schön abkühlen das
mache ich in dem dunklen in einem kühlen
raum am besten zum beispiel in der
abstellkammer oder im keller nicht im
kühlschrank denn da wird sie viel zu
fest die müssen am nächsten tag wieder
weich machen und das ein viel zu großer
aufwand in den nächsten schritt zeige
ich euch jetzt wie ich die torte gefühle
und glatt streichen
das ist ganz wichtig dass die torte
glatt wird dann habt ihr die perfekte
grundlage für die von dort decke dass
ich einfach dieser zucker trägt den mann
dann knetet und ausrollt und das sage
ich jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz mit ihr
den torten retter und stürzt euch mal
die suchen drauf und dann habe ich
nämlich noch das backpapier dran und hat
mir einfach sofort genommen zu hilfe
ferner 18
und auch das backpapier und ihr seht das
hier ist ein richtig schöner feuchte
teil gibt nicht nur das skateboard und
dieses ist fast genauso groß wie die
torte klicks jetzt drauf wie ihr seht
hier am rand ein kleines bisschen drüber
das ist aber nichts schlimmes gleich
wegschneiden das skateboard hatte zum
durchmesser von 25
und jetzt nehme ich mir einfach ein
bisschen garage und streichelte drüber
einfach damit der kuchen dann beim
dekorieren nicht verrutscht drauflegen
und den boden und jetzt habe ich das
ganze auf eine drehbare dort fertig ist
jetzt ein fall hier noch so eine kleines
blech runter und kdc den rand der torte
noch ein bisschen schneiden sie sich
eben unten am keyboard anstoße
ich werde den kuchen jetzt noch halbiert
damit ich ihnen gleich noch erfüllen
kann
wenn ich den boden einfach mit der
drachen flattern abnehmen und jetzt
bestreitet einfach mit etwas
aprikosenmarmelade und schmeckt der
kuchen einfach etwas saftiger und erhält
eben noch mehr feuchtigkeit und jetzt
nehme ich meine kanal schon streich
jetzt hat die erste schicht drauf die
spielt dabei die kunden zu binden damit
die torte einfach nicht krümmel und
gleich eine schöne glatte oberfläche
gekommen
und die wird es einfach für haut
getragen
an der oberfläche und genauso amran
jetzt habe ich den kuchen eingestrichen
und stelle ihn jetzt für etwa 15 bis 20
minuten in den kühlschrank bis die erste
schicht ist mal fest wird und danach
werde ich ihn damit glatt streichen
nach der ersten geschichte ist jetzt nun
die zweite strang
dafür gebe ich gerne auf meine torte und
wehrt sie jetzt wieder glatt streichen
und es ist auch ganz wichtig dass es
jetzt schon sagt wird wir brauchen den
glatten untergrund später für den von
dort damit er eben auch gleich auf
sitzen kann
und bevor ich jetzt den rand wert
streiche gebe ich jetzt noch mal eine
schicht auf die oberseite und streicht
die oberseite komplett flach und daneben
als moderat
und den rand sehe ich jetzt mit einer
chipkarte ab
und so stelle ich jetzt die glatte torte
nochmal in den kühlschrank und kann in
dieser zeit schon einen vom dorf
vorbereiten und ihnen bald könnten zum
überziehen nehme ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen blauen von dort ich brauche
jetzt auch nicht werden
der ist nämlich schon gefärbt und zwar
habe ich jetzt einfach den blauen noch
ein von socken und von den bucks und
habe jetzt drei päckchen bis 750 g und
damit es jetzt gleich nicht an den
händen klebt nämlich einfach etwas
palais und hätte damit meine hände
das ist ein kokosfett und jetzt muss ich
bevor ich es ausbauen kann
erst mal reich kneten
jetzt habe ich mir hier so eine runde
kugel und kann das jetzt schön aus wolle
und dafür nehme ich mir so ein bisschen
becker stärke einfach damit es hier
nicht auf der oberfläche klebt wobei
dieser von dort wirklich nicht klebt und
jetzt leuchtet mit einem großen
silikonen ausrollt stark aus und drehten
von dort immer wieder rund
und dann könnt ihr einfach immer wieder
kontrollieren ob die 100 deckels groß
genug ist bei mir ist's groß genug und
jetzt kann ich es hier auch mein aus
hollstadt aufrollen
man kann es nämlich gleich besser auf
die torte legen
und weil jetzt hier die ganze oberfläche
etwas trocken ist gebe ich jetzt hier
ein bisschen sagt renz die von dort
erkennt gleich darauf kleben bleibt
und jetzt kann ich die decke einfach
drüber ausrollen und jetzt muss ich
zuerst die oberfläche glätten
und dann gehe ich hier an den zeiten
entlang und ketten von oben nach unten
die torte damit die von dort in kiew
nicht in falten legt
jetzt nehme ich hier meine gletscher und
kehrte damit auch schön die oberfläche
und kann jetzt den überschuss hier
einfach mit einem abschneiden
und diese reste die müsst ihr nicht
wegschmeißen die könnte jetzt einfach
immer so zusammen kneten in einen
gefrierbeutel packen und dann einfach in
einen luftdichten box aufbewahren und
die sind dann nicht mehrere monate
haltbar und sein team eine torte wieder
abtrieb latte gesetzt und können es
schön die ränder damit glatt streichen
und jetzt ist meine torte mit vom dollar
überzogen und ich kann sie dekorieren
ich werde mir jetzt gleich eine
schablone nehmen denn ich möchte das
logo und dieser fußballmannschaft machen
von fenerbahce so könnt ihr im prinzip
jede beliebige torte gestalten sie ihr
könnt ihr euch einfach logos zum
beispiel ausdrucken oder bilder
ausdrucken im pferdekopf zum beispiel
und könnte somit der stadtlohnerin
arbeiten und dann eben die torte
gestalten also diese schrecklich so die
einfachste möglichkeit immer machen kann
wenn man eben die torte individuell und
kreativ gestalten will
ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach ganz
kurz und dann sehen wir uns zum schluss
gleichen ich brauche zu den farben her
weiß schwarz rot gelb blau und grün
sprich startet zuerst mit dem großen
weißen kreis und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier zum runde skateboard fast genau da
drauf also ich kann ja von der größe her
wählen wie ich es möchte nehme ich mir
einfach etwas rundes und kann man zb
einen teller oder im deckel geben und
werde jetzt weißen von dort aus rollen
und den daneben ausschlafen
ich hab jetzt hier einen roten preis den
habe ich jetzt bereits etwas trocknen
lassen dann können sie nämlich besser
bewegen und habe das gleiche in grün
blau gemacht und zwar muss ich jetzt
hier das innere blaue abzeichnen
und das machen sie es einfach mit hilfe
des kreises
jetzt lasse ich die teile da oben ganz
kurz antrocknen dann kann ich sie
nämlich später wirklich besser bewegen
und kann jetzt aus meinem buch staaten
ausstellen hatte habe ich hier so ein
paar buchstaben ausstecher und
schlechtes krankenhaus
jetzt hab ich hier alles an geklebt wird
möchte ich hier noch die umwandlungen
machen und das mache ich jetzt hier mit
einer von der presse und zwar kann ich
doch vorne verschiedene seiten einsetzen
und so eine runde scheibe ein
dafür habe ich jetzt hier etwas
schwarzem von drogen und den richtig
schön weich geknetet dann wird es zum
roller gefahren
dann kommt die rolle hier oben rein ist
kann ich mir durch die einfache bewegung
ganz einfach vorne denn von dort aus
presse jetzt nehme ich wieder etwas
zucker kleber und geht es hier entlang
überall da wo sie ziehen möchte
hätte sich hier noch die blätter vorne
und das mache ich jetzt aus grün und
zwar so ich nehme ein kleines stück die
dürfen die auch noch zu groß waren
das zu lange
man fordere es mit blick gestärkt dies
nehme ich mir den fußball werkzeug wird
es auch mit stärke und warum bist du
nicht hier schon aus
die fertige torte könnt ihr direkt
verspeisen oder ihr könnt sie sogar im
kühlschrank einfach aufheben von dann
torten motiv torten dürfen immer in den
kühlschrank die voraussetzung mich
einfach nur dass die unterlage stimmt
also ich kann jetzt keine sahne torte
machen und da ist direkt von dort
überlegen das wird jetzt nur mit modell
ihr schokolade gehen die darf direkt
auch von dort aus sahen das schmilzt
dann nämlich nicht aber von dort
schmilzt eben wenn man ihn direkt auf
seinen liegt jetzt bei der garage ist
natürlich was anderes ist zwar ohne
sahne creme aber da überwiegt einfach
der fettanteil die torte darf im
kühlschrank gelagert werden ihr dürft
ihr einfach nicht abdecken
weil sie ansonsten schwitzt und die
oberfläche daneben feucht wird und so
können dass sie theoretisch am nächsten
tag essen oder sogar bis zum
übernächsten tag also soviel fünf tage
kann man an der torte schon essen und
ich finde dass ich jetzt so eine torte
die kann praktisch jeder nachmachen das
weizer basic video
in zukunft werde ich natürlich auch
wieder etwas anspruchsvolleres machen
für fortgeschrittenere aber mir ist
immer ganz wichtig wenn ich torten
backen gerade bei motiv torten
ich meine wenn man so eine torte sieht
und die sieht richtig toll aus und man
weiß dann reiner die torte schmeckt nach
nichts bin ich sicher ziemlich
enttäuschend deswegen hat man natürlich
seine ansprüche wenn man so eine tolle
torte sieht musste eben auch toll
schmecken und bei mir steht eben der
geschmack immer im vordergrund und dann
erst die dekoration deswegen werdet ihr
zum beispiel bei mir auch nie torten
sehen die total kunstvoll gestaltet sind
es so kunstvoll das eben hauptsächlich
zucker drin steckt denn wenn wir ehrlich
sind dann ist man das ganze zeug dann ja
auch nicht mit und im prinzip wäre es
dann auch wissen so eine
lebensmittelverschwendung und wenn
natürlich auch schade um die ganze
arbeit wenn man sich das stundenlang
eine torte stellt und dann eben die deko
später einfach weggeschmissen wird wenn
sie jetzt bei der torte so wie heute ist
'ich freue denn vom tor richtig dünn aus
als 23 mm kann man den auf jeden fall
mit essen
die alternative wären natürlich entweder
modelle schokolade zu nehmen die hat ja
25% schokoladen anteils schmeckt
natürlich richtig schokoladig oder wenn
man jetzt zum beispiel den kuren dunkel
also brown überziehen will oder schwarz
kann man auch von dort mit schokolade
also mit schokoladengeschmack nehmen den
fans richtig lecker das schmeckt eben
richtig lecker schokolade also fast so
als würde man in so ein schokoriegel
reihenweisen wenn ich total lecker passt
auch sehr gut auch schon getroffen
oder man nimmt die helle variante in
vanille die hat nämlich einen leckeren
vanille geschmack und den kann man dann
auch schön färben ich verlinke euch die
produkte einfach in meine info box da
findet ihr sie und ihr dürft das rezept
auch gerne nachlesen auf sales blog.de
falls ihr jetzt ein motiv deutschen nach
macht würde ich mich über einen facebook
foto freuen oder ein foto auf instagram
da findet er mich auch unter sallys
torten welt oder den morozov sally bott
und ja ich gezeigt viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wie sie beim nächsten mal
wieder bis bald oder holender bessere
mannschaft die mannschaft 18
fußballmannschaft ach ja also hast mich
jetzt nicht dafür dass ich jetzt
fenerbahce gemacht habe ich hasse dich
alles gut